i'll make you one other prediction by  the way which is that the stuff that  you're hearing about uh  chemical weapons is straight out of  their playbook they start saying that uh  there are chemical weapons uh that have  been stored by uh their opponents or by  the americans and so when they  themselves deploy uh chemical weapons as  i as i fear they they may they have us  a sort of a masqueradocar a fake story  ready to go and you've seen it in syria  you you saw it in even in the uk when  this is what you expect next then look i  you know it's i i just note that that is  what they're they're already doing it is  a cynical uh barbaric uh government i'm  afraid